Ben Affleck makes a rare appearance with
son Samuel during a night out at the
Lakers game and my areas of extra cheese
as the kids are spotty at best it's not
homework yeah but Ben's winning some
major dad points with these court-sized
seats and eyewitness sells E.T it was
clear quote they were having a great
time and the 10 year old was quote
really into the game Ben repped for his
hometown of Boston rocking Celtics
colored shoes but Samuel he's an LA kid
he looked cool in a pair of LeBron James
sneakers and while Ben knows a little
something about the game following his
role in the way back
all right 12 seconds no timeouts he was
previously a coach for Samuel's baseball
team the kids are running the right
direction around the bases that knobs
succeed as a coach that's about the
extent of my coaching ability Samuel's
the youngest of Ben and Jennifer
Garner's three kids the exes also share
two daughters 17 year old Violet and 13
year old Serafina and now that Ben's
married to Jennifer Lopez their family
just added a few new names to the roster
yeah Ben and Jen did just that in July
when they exchanged ideas
you look gorgeous
everybody's getting married JLo's twins
Max and Emmy make it five siblings all
together and for the holidays we're
hearing the films sticking together and
Jayla wants to start quote brand new
traditions
I like those Christmas sweaters baby a
store sells E.T the kids helped decorate
the Christmas tree and soon to be under
it lots and lots of gifts our source
says Jen's ready to quote spoil Ben
during their first Christmas as Mr and
Mrs Affleck as for what then we'll get
Gin The Source adds there's quote
sentimental presence that took him a
quote long time to find of course it's
going to be hard for Ben to top his
other gift to JLo earlier this year
he pulled out a ring
so will you marry me
the most perfect moment
and he said it's a green diamond
but as Jennifer recently told Vogue this
year's holiday wish list looks a little
different and what do you want this year
for Christmas
um
I have everything I want